-Ray Donovan
is a fixer of sorts on the show.
Did you talk to people
who had those --
that type of profession
before you started doing this?
-No, I talked to lawyers.
I talked to --
´Cause lawyers are actually
the Ray Donovans of --
Well, not entirely.
But lawyers,
I talked to security guys,
bodyguards, private detectives.
It´s just that Ray sort of does
a little bit of everything.
And there have been guys,
particularly in the Golden Age
of movies, who did it all.
-Yeah.
-But none of those guys
are around anymore.
But I think it --
You know, I really think
it was a brilliant move
by Ann to kind of predict
that our culture
would become so spin-obsessed.
-Sure.
-That a character
like Ray Donovan would --
would really
be a compelling character.
-No, it feels
like everyone these days --
You would not be surprised
to know if anyone in politics
had a fixer.
-That´s right.
-You would say, "Of course.
It would be silly
not to have a fixer.
-It´s sort of de rigueur now.
-Yeah, exactly.
-When you talk to those guys,
people that were
in the bodyguard business,
the security business,
are they excited to talk
to an actor
who´s about play that type?
-I think people
are always generally excited
to talk to an actor who´s about
to play them, I think.
-I guess they have a chance,
too, to try to, like,
politic and make sure
you do it in a way
that makes them seem cooler.
-I think Marty Baron was
probably the exception to that.
-Oh, right.
Sure, of course.
-I took a train down
to meet Marty Baron,
who I am a huge fan of
as an editor.
-Right.
A great admirer of his.
And I don´t think there could´ve
been two more nervous guys
in a room than me
and Marty Baron talking to --
He´s not someone
who I think really is interested
in his own story.
-Well, yeah, I would imagine
because he´s so much
on the side of the news
that presents it.
-Right.
-Like, I -- It strikes me
as he´s someone who believes
the more invisible he is
the better the news story.
-The better he is
at doing his job, yeah.
-He must´ve been psyched,
though, that Liev Schreiber
was playing him, right?
-I don´t know.
-Yeah.
-If I´m Marty Baron
and I see Ray Donovan walk in,
I´m a little worried.
-Yeah, I think so, too, yeah.
No, Ray Donovan
comes from Boston.
-He does.
-He´s from Southie.
So you have to, as an actor --
One of the great hurdles of any
actor is the Boston accent.
-Yeah.
-How do you feel?
Do you feel good about it?
-I feel like we did okay.
I fee like I´m pretty good
at it --
-That´s the best grade
you´ll ever get
from a person from Boston.
-What´s that?
-"Okay."
Yeah, no one from Boston
is like, "You did it, bro.
We´re so proud of you."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"It´s all right."
-"We´re so proud a kid
from New York got it right."
[ Laughter ]
-"No, you did good."
I went to school
in Massachusetts,
and I used to hang out
with a guy
who was a crazy Pats fan
from Southie.
And I kind of -- I´m kind of
ripping him off a little bit.
But we did make
one huge mistake...
-Okay.
-...that any Southie
probably knows,
if there are any Southies
in the house tonight.
We called the character
Ray Donovan.
-Yeah,
that´s what I would´ve done.
-It´s "Dunovan."
-"Dunovan." Interesting.
-If you´re a Southie or Irish,
it´s "Dunovan," and, uh...
So we´ve been screwing it up
for six years, but, uh...
-But I´m sure people --
-We´ve got another season
of "Ray Donovan" coming.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you should --
There should be a moment where,
like, you get a --
You know, maybe you do
one of those shows,
like Ray Donovan --
Here´s just a pitch.
-You do, like, one of those
"finding your roots" shows.
You know, like, the character.
-Oh, it goes back?
-He goes back
and finds hit root.
And then the character
finds out, they say,
"Actually, it´s Dunovan,"
and then you just change it.
-That´s brilliant.
-Yeah.
-I´m gonna tell David.
-Yeah, okay, perfect.
Thanks so much for being here.